hey legal eagles there are a lot of
extracurriculars available to students
in law school but the choices can seem
overwhelming they are very different
from what you can do in college
so what extracurriculars are out there
and what should you spend your time on
in law school well by the end of this
video you will have a really good idea
of which extracurricular is for you what
will add to your resume and what is a
good use of your time in law school so
stick around alright so first and
foremost extracurriculars can be very
rewarding in law school but generally
speaking grades are more important when
you're in law school
so while it may be tempting to sign up
for lots of extracurriculars especially
during the first week of class as a
general rule you never want to sacrifice
your grades for spending time in
extracurricular activities and that goes
for even the most prestigious
extracurriculars like participating on
Law Review it's almost always better to
have good grades than it is to
participate in lots of extracurriculars
so with that being said and without
further ado here are the most popular
extracurriculars in law school and my
opinion as to how valuable they are and
I should tell you I know what I'm
talking about in addition to working in
big law for over ten years
I have recruited for big firms I have
interviewed many law students for
Associate jobs and I have read more law
student resumes than I could possibly
count so let's talk about the most
popular extracurriculars in law school
the first one and the most popular and
usually the most highly regarded is law
review generally law schools have one
flagship law review a law review is a
weird student-run publication that
publishes papers by professors
professionals and other academics while
other fields have peer reviewed journals
that are run by professionals or experts
in the field law schools have these
student-run publications that do two
things they review curate and proof the
academic papers mostly of profess
sirs and then publish them and law
reviews will publish the papers of
students who are on Law Review and those
are called notes sometimes without
attribution to the individual student
who produced it but the Law Review
serves the purpose of publishing
academic papers they tend to be the most
prestigious legal journals in the legal
field and they also publish the papers
of students now if you want to publish
in law school you should join Law Review
there are generally also a lot of other
journals or law reviews that specialize
in different topics but almost always
the most prestigious journal in a
particularly is the Law Review and there
are a couple very famous ones the
Harvard Law Review comes to mind it's an
incubator for future professors and
legal scholars it's really the top of
the field when it comes to legal
publications and while there are a
number of different journals and law
reviews in law school generally the main
lauter view is the most prestigious it
can be a real resume bump out of all the
things that you can do in law school as
an extracurricular there is no doubt
that participating in the Maine Law
Review for your law school is by far the
most prestigious extracurricular that
you can do it is a real resume bump
especially when you get to the top law
schools where the Law Review itself has
an actual reputation in the field but
that being said it is a ton of hard work
you are constantly proofing and
reviewing different papers only a few of
which are going to be published it's
really thankless work it is very
persnickety you have to have a real eye
for proofing you have to be a very good
writer and it's also very difficult to
get on to the Law Review some law
reviews require you to have top grades
before you can participate and other law
reviews have a straight merit-based
system based on writing on to the
journal so you show a writing sample and
that's how you get on other law reviews
have a combination of the two where some
people will grade on and some people
will write on but once you get on to Law
Review you can anticipate that you're
going to
and a lot of time doing writing related
activities a lot of proofing and a lot
of publishing related work so that
brings me to the second most popular
extracurricular in law school and that
is moot court moot court is where
students pretend to be appellate
attorneys students will write appellate
briefs and then they will argue that
brief usually on a very narrow part of
the law in front of a panel of judges
this panel of judges is sometimes real
judges if the school is able to get the
judges to participate but usually some
lawyers from the community who are
judging the students on their ability to
argue on either the appellate brief
and/or their oral argument ability in
front of them there are a number of
different moot courts some specialize in
international law or patent law and some
are just sort of a general civil or
criminal appellate jurisdiction where
they'll give you a topic that is of wide
appeal and you'll argue that particular
topic some moot courts are just for the
particular school where it's just
amongst students in that school and some
are against schools from around the city
or state where students will be
competing against each other in some
moot courts you're graded on the brief
and some it's just your oral argument
and some is a combination of the two now
moot court is certainly a resume bump
not as much as law review but if you
have moot court especially if you are a
successful moot court competitor then
employers will look favorably on that in
your resume especially if you can show
that you are someone who was very good
at arguing very good at writing those
are the kind of skills that future
employers want to see so it's not quite
as prestigious as law review and it's
not quite as much of a bump in your
resume but it's certainly a positive
mark on your law school resume it's also
a great way to hone your oral argument
skills it feels like there's a bit of a
bait-and-switch when you get to law
school where you think you're gonna be
arguing all the time but really you're
just sitting in a lecture hall listening
to your
sir and at most you're going back and
forth in the Socratic method when he he
or she peppers you with questions but
this is one of the true places where you
are able to get better at arguing and
have a chance to compete in that that
type of competition so that brings me to
the third most common extracurricular in
law school and that is mock trial
don't get mock trial and moot court
confused if moot court is a simulation
of appellate advocacy then mock trial is
a simulation of a real trial at the
trial court level I did both moot court
and mock trial in law school and while
moot court is a lot of fun and it's
great I thought mock trial was way more
fun you get to do all the aspects of a
trial you're going to do opening
statement examination of witnesses cross
examinations closings objections
it's like law and order but in real life
but still fake if that makes sense it's
not dissimilar to mock trial in high
school or in college but it's operating
at a much higher level there are
different mock trials and they vary by
topic there are civil mock trials there
are criminal mock trial competitions
there are employment mock trial
competitions there are a lot of
different formats to in in some mock
trials you provide your own witnesses in
other words their fellow law students
who are training to be a witness and you
prep them ahead of time and in some mock
trials the competition actually gives
you a witness that you've never met
before and you only have a couple of
minutes to prep them before they go on
on the witness stand so there are a lot
of different venues that can be a lot of
fun to participate in because they're so
varied mock trial is probably less
prestigious than Law Review and moot
court but I would say that people in the
know really understand that mock trial
is an incubator for people who really
want to be in court so you can show that
you have the skills of a real practicing
trial attorney if you hone them in mock
trial so while it's not quite as much of
a resume boost as
court and law review um it's still
something that's worthwhile doing if
you're prepared for the time commitment
so that brings me to the next
extracurricular in law school it is by
far the most popular and it's the one
that almost every law student
participates in and that is drinking
there's a lot of drinking in law school
I'm talking in jest that is an
extracurricular but I am Telling You
this for two reasons one is that your
social life is an important aspect of
law school you should go out and you
should meet other people and have a
little fun on occasion and number two is
that when people go out to go drinking
they usually call it bar review and the
first time anyone ever hears that
they're going to bar review on Thursday
night they often make the assumption
that it's a study group it's not bar
review means going out for drinks just
FYI you have been warned it happens and
you know go out once in a while it's
it's worthwhile okay so back to all
seriousness the next extracurricular is
the various student groups on campus
there are a lot of student groups in law
school you have human rights groups you
have ethnic and cultural groups
the Federalist Society outlaw black law
students there are a lot of social
groups and cultural groups that it's
sort of a loose Association they try and
bring speakers in they often hold
conferences and this isn't that much of
a resume boost but it's a great way to
network so I wouldn't discount it
entirely it's a it's also a good way to
meet friends and other attorneys in the
community who share similar values to
you so you know a part of law school
that most people overlook is networking
and you know you should spend some time
getting to know people in the community
especially if you want to work in that
community because it's a great way to
form a social network of your own that
may come in handy when you're looking
for jobs later down the line so after
that I would say the last big
extracurricular our social committees in
law school these are things like
participating on law prom putting
together the Big Dance for law
students if your school has a law school
musical putting together the musical
there are also public interest
committees and various fundraising
activities again like the social
organizations these are not necessarily
big resume boosters but they're great
for networking and a great way to spend
some time on something other than the
black letter law in your particular cap
classes which you know sometimes we get
tunnel vision and we focus just on
studying and and not other social
aspects of law school so I don't
discount the social committees as well
now if you want even more information
and strategies and tactics before you
get to law school please download our
free ultimate pre-law checklist it's our
free gift to you the link to that is
below it will help you demystify law
school and also please click on the like
and subscribe buttons the more people
that subscribe the more videos we'll
make on how to crush law school so what
extracurriculars are you going to
participate in let me know in the
comments below and until next time at
legal eagle think like a lawyer and ace
the exam what you should spend your time
[Music]
amended bill okay